Bonjour à tous! Aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler de cette théorie célèbre
et pourtant bien mystérieuse, qu'on appelle la théorie des cordes.
La théorie des cordes vous le savez sans doute c'est
une théorie qui prétend unifier dans un seul cadre
toute la physique fondamentale, ce qu'on appelle
prétentieusement une théorie du tout.
Si vous avez suivi mon épisode
sur Stephen Hawking,
vous savez que la principale difficulté quand
on essaye de faire une théorie du tout,
c'est celle d'unifier ensemble la mécanique
quantique et la relativité générale.
La mécanique quantique c'est la théorie qui permet
de décrire la matière au niveau microscopique
c'est-à-dire les atomes le noyau des
atomes et puis toute la physique des particules.
à côté de ça, la relativité générale c'est la théorie
qui décrit plutôt le monde de l'infiniment grand.
C'est à dire le mouvement des galaxies
les trous noirs,
l'expansion de l'univers et puis
jusqu'à la théorie du big bang.
quand on dit qu'on veut unifier ensemble
la mécanique quantique et la relativité générale,
ça laisse un peu sous-entendre que ces
deux théories se situeraient sur le même plan.
En fait ce sont deux théories dont la
nature est très différente.
La relativité générale c'est une théorie
qui décrit une force, la force de gravité.
A la limite on pourrait la comparer à des
théories qui décrivent d'autres forces
comme par exemple la théorie de Coulomb
qui décrit la force électrostatique
entre deux particules chargées.
Ou alors un petit peu plus compliqué la théorie de
Maxwell qui décrit la force électromagnétique.
La mécanique quantique à côté de ça
c'est pas une théorie qui décrit une force,
c'est plutôt un ensemble de principes qui
permettent de comprendre comment les forces
se comportent au niveau microscopique.
Donc si par exemple vous avez une
théorie qui décrit une force
et dont vous savez qu'elle est correcte
au niveau macroscopique,
ce que la mécanique quantique vous dit, c'est
qu'il y a toutes les chances que votre théorie
ne fonctionne pas au niveau microscopique.
par contre la mécanique quantique
vous donne une série de guides
qui vont vous permettre de fabriquer une
version quantique de votre théorie
qui va fonctionner au niveau microscopique.
C'est ce qu'on appelle faire la
quantification d'une théorie.
On peut prendre un exemple.
Si vous considérez la théorie de Coulomb
qui permet de décrire l'interaction électrostatique,
Vous pouvez utiliser cette théorie pour
décrire
la manière dont une charge négative, par exemple,
va tourner autour d'une charge positive.
Si vos deux charges sont au niveau
macroscopique ça va bien fonctionner,
par contre si vous voulez utiliser cette théorie
pour décrire la manière dont un
électron tourne autour d'un proton
au niveau microscopique, la théorie
ne va plus marcher.
Mais la mécanique quantique vous permet
d'adapter cette théorie en la quantifiant
et en fabriquant ce qui est en fait la théorie
quantique de l'atome d'hydrogène.
On peut prendre un exemple plus compliqué.
Si vous considérez la force électromagnétique,
c'est une force un petit peu plus
générale que juste l'électrostatique.
Au niveau macroscopique elle est
décrite par la théorie de Maxwell
et c'est cette théorie qui permet
notamment de comprendre
comment les ondes électromagnétiques se propagent.
Par exemple les ondes lumineuses
ou les ondes radio.
Au niveau microscopique cette théorie
ne va pas fonctionner,
mais si vous lui appliquez les principes de la
mécanique quantique, que vous la quantifiez,
vous tombez sur une théorie qu'on
appelle l'électrodynamique quantique
et qui permet de comprendre le comportement
de la lumière au niveau microscopique
et par exemple de montrer qu'au niveau
microscopique la lumière est faite de photons.
Cette théorie de l'électrodynamique quantique
a notamment été beaucoup développée
par un certain Richard Feynman
et vous allez voir qu'on va reparler
de Feynman dans un instant.
Donc vous voyez que le problème d'unifier
mécanique quantique et relativité générale
c'est simplement le problème d'arriver à appliquer
les principes de la mécanique quantique
à la force de gravité décrite par la
relativité générale.
La théorie de la relativité générale décrit bien
la force de gravité au niveau macroscopique.
Ce qu'on aimerait arriver à faire
c'est à quantifier cette théorie
pour fabriquer une théorie de la force de gravité
qui fonctionne au niveau microscopique,
ce qu'on appelle hypothétiquement une
théorie de la gravité quantique.
D'ailleurs souvent le problème de la théorie
du tout on l'appelle simplement
le problème de la gravité quantique.
Le problème c'est qu'appliquer les principes de la
mécanique quantique à une théorie macroscopique,
c'est pas du tout simple.
Je vous ai présenté ça comme si c'était une
sorte de procédure automatique.
En fait c'est plutôt une sorte de recette de cuisine un
petit peu floue qui nous dit comment il faudrait faire,
mais c'est pas du tout immédiat.
Et l'autre difficulté c'est qu'il faut en
général utiliser des objets mathématiques
qui sont beaucoup plus compliqués que les
objets mathématiques qu'on avait au départ.
Si vous connaissez un tout petit peu la
théorie quantique de l'atome d'hydrogène,
vous savez que ça utilise des maths
qui sont quand même un chouïa plus
compliquées que la description de la force de Coulomb.
En pratique c'est même tellement compliqué
d'appliquer les principes de la mécanique quantique,
qu'on n'y arrive quasiment jamais de
manière exacte.
Dans le cas de l'atome d'hydrogène,
on y arrive parce que c'est très simple
mais dès qu'on passe à quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus compliqué,
comme par exemple le champ électromagnétique,
on n'y arrive plus.
C'est d'ailleurs même un problème de
recherche en maths
que de trouver les bons objets qui
permettent de décrire de manière exacte
certaines théories quantiques
des champs.
Il y a même un des prix du millénaire, vous savez
les prix à un million de dollars en mathématiques,
qui est consacré à une question technique
de la théorie quantique des champs.
Donc en pratique les physiciens ont
été obligés de faire une simplification
pour arriver à appliquer les principes de la mécanique
quantique à des théories comme l'électromagnétisme.
Ils ont été obligés de faire ce qu'on
appelle de la quantification perturbative.
L'idée la quantification perturbative c'est en gros
de considérer que toutes les situations auxquelles
on a affaire ne sont que des petites
perturbations autour d'une situation bien connue.
Pour reprendre une analogie, c'est comme si
vous vouliez étudier les mouvements de l'océan,
et que vous disiez que vous allez vous
limiter simplement à l'étude
des petites vaguelettes à la
surface d'une eau calme.
Dans le cas du champ électromagnétique ce principe
de perturbations n'est pas complètement absurde,
puisqu'en général, quand on a un photon
qui passe ou une onde lumineuse,
les champs électriques et magnétiques
associés sont très petits.
Donc on peut considérer que
ce sont des petites perturbations.
Si on applique le principe de la quantification
perturbative à l'électromagnétisme
on tombe donc sur cette théorie quon appelle
l'électrodynamique quantique.
L'électrodynamique quantique, je vous l'ai dit,
elle a notamment été beaucoup développée
par Richard Feynman.
Et Feynman a mis au point un outil qui est au cœur
de toutes les méthodes de quantification perturbative.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les diagrammes de Feynman.
Si vous ouvrez un livre de physique des particules
vous allez voir que c'est truffé de petits dessins
et ces petits dessins donc,
les diagrammes de Feynman,
ils sont là pour représenter des
interactions entre particules.
Par exemple sur le diagramme qu'on voit
ici on a un électron et un positron
qui se rencontrent, qui s'anihilent
ensemble pour donner un photon
et puis un petit peu plus tard ce photon
se redésintègre en un électron et un positron.
Ces petits dessins il ne sont pas juste là pour
représenter ou illustrer des phénomènes.
C'est aussi des équations, c'est-à-dire qu'un
physicien des particules est capable de traduire
ce dessin en équation, de mettre un nombre dessus et
ce nombre va représenter la probabilité que
l’événement qu'on a dessiné se produise.
La quantification perturbative ça marche extrêmement
bien puisque ça a permis de fabriquer
les versions quantiques de trois
des quatre forces fondamentales.
Vous savez, on dit souvent qu'il y a
quatre forces fondamentales.
La force électromagnétique, la force
nucléaire forte, la force nucléaire faible
et la force de gravité décrite
par la relativité générale.
Et bien la quantification perturbative on a
réussi à l'appliquer aux trois premières
et en mettant ensemble ce qu'on a
obtenu on a formé
le modèle standard de la physique des particules.
Le modèle standard de la physique des
particules c'est la théorie qui décrit
aujourd'hui toute la physique des particules connues.
c'est une théorie qui est extrêmement
bien confirmée expérimentalement avec
toutes les expériences qui ont été faites
dans les accélérateurs de particules.
D'ailleurs la dernière pièce à l'édifice a été ajoutée il n'y
a pas longtemps avec la découverte du boson de Higgs.
Evidemment quand on voit ça, la
première chose qu'on se dit c'est:
si on veut fabriquer la version
quantique de la relativité générale
on n'a qu'à appliquer la méthode qui a
fonctionné avec les autres forces.
On n'a qu'à appliquer la quantification perturbative.
Et bien le problème c'est qu'appliquer la quantfication
perturbative à la relativité générale, ça ne marche pas.
Immaginons que vous vouliez appliquer les principes
de la quantification perturbative à la relativité générale.
Vous allez faire comme dans les autres
théories, c'est-à-dire que vous avez commencer
à écrire les diagrammes de Feynman
qui sont associés.
Je vous ai dit, ces diagrammes de Feynman
ils représentent des nombres,
ils représentent des probabilités
que les événements se produisent.
Le problème c'est que si vous faites
ça, dans le cas de la relativité générale,
les diagrammes de Feynman ils valent
toujours l'infini.
C'est-à-dire que vous obtenez une théorie
où dès que vous essayez de calculer
quelque chose de physique avec, la théorie vous répond: l'infini.
Donc utiliser les principes de la quantification
perturbative pour la relativité générale,
ça ne marche pas
Et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important à comprendre
parce que c'est le point de départ de toutes les
autres approches qui ont été développées depuis
pour essayer de fabriquer une théorie
de la gravité quantique.
Donc, qu'ont fait les théoriciens des
cordes pour contourner ce problème?
Et bien, ils ont décidé de reprendre les
choses un petit peu à la base
et de faire l'hypothèse que l'univers
n'est pas fait de particules ponctuelles
mais qu'il est fait de petites cordes.
Alors qu'est-ce que ça change?
Quand vous avez une particule qui se déplace,
elle trace une ligne dans l'espace,
alors que quand vous avez une corde - il faut s'imaginer
un petit cercle - il va tracer un tube.
Donc si vous reprenez la méthode de quantification
perturbative en prenant en compte ce changement,
les diagrammes de Feynman au lieu d'être
des petites lignes qui se branchent entre elles,
ça devient des petits tubes qui
se branchent entre eux.
Au delà du changement sur le
dessin, ce qui est très important
c'est que que ça fait disparaître les infinis qui
apparaissaient autrement dans le calcul.
C'est-à-dire que faire cette hypothèse
que le monde est fait de petites cordes,
ça résout le problème fondamental qui était que
la quantification perturbative ne fonctionnait pas
avec la relativité générale.
Ça c'est la première bonne nouvelle.
L'autre grande nouvelle, c'est que dans le modèle
standard de la physique des particules,
vous avez besoin de supposer qu'il existe
plein de types de particules différents,
des neutrinos, des électrons, des quarks.
En théorie des cordes vous n'avez
besoin que d'un seul type de corde.
Pourquoi? Parce qu'une corde peut vibrer sur
elle-même un peu comme une corde de guitare
et comme une corde de guitare, elle peut
vibrer de différentes manières
qu'on appelle les différents modes.
Les différents modes de vibration
d'une corde permettent de produire
les différents types de particules qu'on
trouve dans le modèle standard.
C'est-à-dire qu'au lieu d'avoir à introduire
plein de types de particules différents,
vous utilisez seulement un seul type de corde.
Ça c'était pour les bonnes nouvelles.
Maintenant, dans les mauvaises nouvelles, il y a quand
même un petit problème avec la théorie des cordes.
Il y a ce qu'on appelle une anomalie, c'est quelque chose
qui rend la théorie inconsistante au niveau quantique.
Et le seul moyen de se débarrasser
de cette inconsistance,
c'est de changer le nombre de
dimensions de l'espace-temps.
Suivant les versions de la théorie des cordes,
il faut utiliser soit 26 dimensions soit 10 dimensions.
En fait la théorie à 26 dimensions on sait que
pour d'autres raisons elle n'est pas correcte
donc toutes les théories modernes des
cordes imposent d'utiliser 10 dimensions.
10 dimensions ça veut dire, une dimension
de temps et 9 dimensions d'espace.
Le problème c'est que jusqu'ici des dimensions
d'espace je n'en connait que 3,
donc je veux bien qu'il y en ait 9 mais il
faut m'expliquer où sont les 6 autres.
L'astuce qu'ont trouvée les théoriciens des cordes,
c'est de dire:
les six dimensions supplémentaires,
en fait on ne les voit pas
parce qu'elles sont très petites et qu'elles
sont repliées sur elles-mêmes.
Pour comprendre ça, on peut
considérer le cas d'un plan.
Prenez une feuille de papier,
imaginez qu'elle est infinie
donc vous avez 2 dimensions,
les deux dimensions sont infinies.
Maintenant si au lieu de considérer une feuille de papier,
vous considérez un très long cylindre de papier,
vous voyez qu'il y a toujours 2 dimensions,
sauf que cette fois vous avez une dimension infinie
et une dimension qui est finie
et elle est finie parce qu'elle est
repliée sur elle-même.
Maintenant, imaginez que vous regardez un cylindre
de très loin, par exemple, un fil de fer.
Ce cylindre a toujours deux dimensions,
sauf qu'une des dimensions
- la dimension qui est finie -
est tellement petite qu'on ne la voit pas.
et donc on peut avoir l'impression qu'il
n'y a qu'une dimension alors qu'en fait il y en a 2.
C'est ce principe-là qui, d'après les théoriciens
des cordes permet d'expliquer que
les six dimensions supplémentaires de
l'espace on ne les voit pas.
C'est parce qu'elles sont cachées,
elles sont de taille finie et très petites.
Pour comprendre comment on va
décrire ça mathématiquement,
on peut revenir sur le cas du cylindre.
Un cylindre, géométriquement, on peut le
représenter comme étant une droite
et en chaque point de ma droite,
je dessine un petit cercle.
Mathématiquement, on dit qu'un cylindre
c'est une droite fois un cercle.
L'avantage cette écriture, c'est qu'elle permet de mettre
en évidence le fait qu'il y a une dimension infinie
et une dimension finie.
Avant de passer au cas de la théorie des cordes,
je voudrais juste qu'on regarde un cas
un petit peu plus compliqué.
Imaginons que je veuille fabriquer un
espace à quatre dimensions,
deux dimensions infinies et deux
dimensions finies.
Pour faire mes deux dimensions infinie,
je vais prendre un plan
et puis, en chaque point de mon plan, je vais
poser un petit espace à 2 dimensions finies.
L'espace à 2 dimensions finies le plus simple
auquel je puisse penser c'est une sphère.
Donc, si vous posez en chaque point de
votre plan une petite sphère,
vous obtenez un espace qui est: le plan fois la sphère.
2 dimensions infinies, 2 dimensions finies.
J'ai choisi la sphère mais ce n'était pas le seul choix
possible, j'aurais pu par exemple prendre le tore.
Le tore c'est une surface en forme de bouée.
Si en chaque point de mon plan je pose un petit tore,
j'obtiens un nouvel espace qui est: le plan fois le tore.
C'est aussi un espace à quatre
dimensions dont deux finies
mais qui est différent de celui que j'avais avant.
Passons maintenant au cas de la théorie des cordes.
Je vous ai dit, pour faire de la théorie
des cordes, il faut dix dimensions.
Une dimension de temps et 9 dimensions d'espace.
Sur ces 9 dimensions d'espace,
on va en prendre 3 qui vont être infinies,
c'est les dimensions habituelles
et on en veut 6 qui soient finies.
Donc pour représenter ça, on veut prendre
notre espace tridimensionnel habituel
et en chaque point de l'espace on veut poser
un petit espace à 6 dimensions finies.
Les gens qui font de la théorie des cordes ont regardé
quels étaient les espaces qui pouvaient convenir
et ils se sont rendus compte que
les espaces qui marchaient
correspondaient à ce qu'on appelle en mathématiques:
les espaces de Calabi-Yau,
du nom des deux mathématiciens
qui ont travaillé dessus.
Un espace de Calabi-Yau, c'est assez difficile
à se représenter puisque ça a 6 dimensions,
mais on peut essayer de le représenter en
le projetant en 2 ou 3 dimensions
et donc ça donne des choses comme ça. Vous voyez, c'est assez joli.
Le problème c'est que de même que tout à l'heure
je pouvais m'amuser à choisir
une shère ou un tore comme
espace à 2 dimensions finies,
là, j'ai le choix entre plein d'espaces
de Calabi-Yau à 6 dimensions.
Et c'est très important de savoir lequel je vais
choisir pour faire de la théorie des cordes,
puisque je vous ai dit: les cordes vibrent,
et donc elles vont vibrer dans les dimensions
de l'espace de Calabi-Yau.
Et la manière dont les cordes vibrent
détermine les propriétés des particules
qu'on va trouver dans la théorie.
Ça veut dire que si moi je commence
à faire de la théorie des cordes
en choisissant un espace de Calabi-Yau
et que mon voisin, il fait de la théorie
des cordes et qu'il en prend un autre,
on va fabriquer deux théories ayant
des propriétés physiques différentes,
ayant des particules différentes.
Donc, il y a autant de théories des cordes possibles
que de manières de choisir l'espace de Calabi-Yau.
Le problème c'est qu'entre le choix
de l'espace de Calabi-Yau
et les autres choix qu'il faut faire pour
fabriquer une théorie des cordes,
- c'est ce qu'on appelle le problème du choix du vide -
on se rend compte qu'on peut fabriquer
peut-être jusqu'à 10 puissance 100
théorie des cordes différentes.
Pour les critiques de la théorie des cordes,
cette abondance de choix
rend la théorie complètement inutilisable.
Si vous avez 10 puissance 100 versions
de votre théorie,
ça veut dire que chaque fois que vous essayez
de faire une prédiction expérimentale,
vous avez 10 puissance 100 prédictions expérimentales
et donc dans ces conditions comment
on peut tester la théorie.
Si demain quelqu'un se pointe avec un
résultat expérimental nouveau,
vous allez toujours trouver une
tétrachiée de théories des cordes
qui sont capables d'expliquer ce
résultat expérimental.
Et même pour les plus virulents critiques, du coup
la théorie des cordes n'est pas une science
puisqu'on ne peut pas la tester expérimentalement.
Les partisans de la théorie des cordes ont réussi
à retourner l'argument à leur avantage
avec l'idée du multivers.
Le multivers ça consiste à supposer qu'il existerait
une multitude d'univers comme le nôtre,
qui seraient déconnectés les uns des
autres,
et qui seraient potentiellement régis par
des lois physiques différentes.
Donc les partisans de la théorie des
cordes disent: ça se trouve il existe
autant d'univers que de variantes
possibles de la théorie des cordes.
Chacun de ces univers obéit à une théorie
des cordes construite, par exemple,
avec un espace de Calabi-Yau différent
et donc il déboucherait sur des lois
physiques différentes.
Et nous, on vit simplement dans un de ces univers.
Mais tout n'est pas perdu pour tester la théorie
des cordes parce qu'il y a quand même un ingrédient
de la théorie des cordes qu'on peut
espérer vérifier expérimentalement.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la supersymétrie.
La supersymétrie, je n'en ai pas encore parlé, mais
c'est un ingrédient essentiel de la théorie des cordes.
C'est une symétrie qui suppose qu'il y aurait,
en fait, deux fois plus de types de particules
que ce qu'on croyait avant.
Si on regarde aujourd'hui dans le
modèle standard de la physique des particules
et qu'on compte absolument
toutes les particules,
les quarks, les électrons, les neutrinos etc... et
toutes leurs antiparticules,
on trouve qu'il y a 61 types de
particules différentes
Et bien, la supersymétrie elle suppose
qu'il en existerait en fait deux fois plus
parce que chacune de ces particules aurait une
sorte de double, ce qu'on appelle le superpartenaire.
Et pour les nommer on s'amuse à
rajouter un petit s devant.
Donc le superpartenaire du quark c'est le squark et le
superpartenaire de l'électron c'est le sélectron etc...
Aujourd'hui on n'a jamais vu une seule de ces 61
particules supplémentaires, les superpartenaires.
Mais les spécialistes de la supersymétrie
pensent que normalement,
au LHC, dans le collisionneur du
CERN,
on commence à atteindre des énergies où on
devrait voir ces particules, si elles existent.
Si dans les prochains runs du LHC qui vont
avoir lieu dans les prochaines années
on ne voit aucune de ces
particules supersymétriques,
ça peut signifier que la
supersymétrie n'existe pas
et donc ça serait un sérieux problème
pour la théorie des cordes.
Si finalement la théorie des cordes devait
finir par être démentie expérimentalement,
ça ne serait quand même
pas la fin des haricots.
C'est vrai que c'est jusqu'à aujourd'hui
l'approche qui a été la plus étudiée
mais ce n'est pas la seule qui existe pour essayer
de fabriquer une théorie de la gravité quantique.
Notamment, il existe une autre approche que j'ai déjà
mentionnée qui s'appelle la gravité quantique à boucles.
Pour comprendre en quoi la gravité quantique
à boucles diffère de la théorie des cordes,
Il faut se rappeler que le point de
départ de tout ça c'est que
la quantification perturbative de la
relativité générale donne des infinis.
Le chemin qu'ont choisi les gens qui font de
la gravité quantique à boucles, c'est de dire:
si la quantification perturbative ne marche pas,
il faut faire de la quantification non-perturbative.
Le problème c'est que faire de la quantification
non perturbative c'est beaucoup plus difficile.
Ça oblige notamment à utiliser des objets
mathématiques qui sont beaucoup plus complexes
et donc c'est en quelque
sorte le chemin difficile.
Le gros avantage c'est que la gravité
quantique à boucles elle n'a pas besoin
de faire des hypothèses supplémentaires
sur des chose qu"on n'a jamais vues.
par exemple elle n'a pas besoin de supposer
que le monde est fait de petites cordes,
elle n'a pas besoin de supposer
qu'il y a la supersymétrie
et elle n'a pas non plus besoin de supposer
qu'il y a des dimensions supplémentaires.
Mais bon, tout ça je vous le
raconterait une prochaine fois.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, n'hésitez
pas à la partager pour faire connaître
la théorie des cordes au monde entier.
Vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne,
vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon blog
qui s'appelle "Science Étonnante"
et vous pouvez également me suivre
sur Facebook et sur Twitter.
Si vous ne les avez pas déjà vues, bien sûr,
je vous invite à aller voir mes vidéos précédentes.
A bientôt!
Sous-titres: Warteks